la ja panne est triple in her vi est une
plante exotique introduite dans
l'archipel des mascareignes
à la fin du xviiie siècle originaire
d'amazonie
les indiens l'utiliser pour la
cicatrisation des morsures de serpent à
la réunion on connaît plus cette plante
miracle pour ses multiples vertus
calmantes la pana un petit plant que les
très connu et très apprécié dans presque
tout jardin créole demi pensionnat
lapidé par le mounier apprécié ça pour
ses vertus digestives c'est à dire après
mon bon bien manger ou d'un petit
ballonnements problème dit session tout
de suite at ease indépendant et il n'ya
pas d'aller facile à reconnaître
comprend tiefensee epona 3 né à vue à la
c'est pour ça il ya peu sa triple
service à praia trapenard il ya plein
trip ineris 3 nervures 1 2 3 à ne pas
confondre avec le gros la pana que les
plantes et à l'entrée des cours que les
toxiques de monique visant ben moi non
c'est un petit peu peut-être un petit
excès comme ça et me servait un petit
problème de digestion carrément nîmes à
sa feuille comme ça c'est incroyable
en cinq minutes le problème est réglé
bon pas besoin bombay à trois petits
failli à pana pour trois quarts l'italie
de l'eau en infusion un maître palier à
bouillir pas trop intéressante aux faits
bruit de l'eau quand de la bouillie ou
vh dessus la cia ont fusé pendant 15
minutes à peu près impeccable le moule
est appréciable et celle à pouvoir sont
les faits que les intéressants voilà un
peu plus compliqué que ça petit la
fusion diana et d'anis nous a bien mangé
rae ne va boire ça juste après pour bien
digérer voit la petite tisane et pana et
alice à nice bien mélanger la peut
rajouter un petit peu dangereux en
dedans y fera pas de mal voilà il ya
cinq six personnes navarre la dose ou
cinq six personnes il va mettre ça dans
un petit qui respire l'impôt versé là
dessus de l'eau que la bourriche de
sautes chaudes sont bonnes
on va laisser ça voilà la plante ne
commencent à changer de couleur la voix
bien et ça commence à être parfumée
aussi on sent la bonne tisane d'un
troisième répondre à la réunion ils
trouvent ça dans les eaux un peu partout
sur les montagnes mafate pas tout
roussat les faits certains petits frères
blanc c'est les abeilles sera bon peu là
dessus quand une ampleur c'est le gros
il ya pas d'amalgamé peines aggravées
par des malgaches et aussi abc huit
années passées le bc oui ça l'est
beaucoup plus
use les tees beaucoup plus foncée et les
feuilles les nervures n'est pas pareil
et donc ça ne m est pas dans tisane ni
les toc site web mozilla mais n'était
pas présent